aujourd'hui je répète on est là
aujourd'hui un dans une logique
simplement d'informations de la
délégation sur un sujet important qui
occupe une part importante de 20 des
territoires donc l'alsace
nous n'avons pas vocation aujourd'hui à
prendre position même si un certain
nombre d'entre vous peut être vont le
faire mais la délégation n'a pas
vocation à prendre position
et puis tu as faim aujourd'hui sur aucun
des scénarios est de même de donner un
avis donc c'est simplement un échange
pour que chacun et une bonne
connaissance de ce dossier je me permet
de résumer ce qui est un exercice
difficile il ya une synthèse
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît je
permets de le résumer un petit peu le
rapport mc est une synthèse qui est
plutôt plutôt bien fait mais en quelques
mots je souhaite attirer votre attention
sur quatre points le premier il existe
une spécificité alsacienne indiscutable
sur les plans historique juridique avec
un droit alsaciens mosellans
géographique du fait de son caractère
frontaliers et économiques dans ces
conditions il n'est pas illégitime que
l'on se pose la question de la prise en
compte de ses spécificités dans la
définition de l'organisation
institutionnelle
je me permets de préciser là que ce
sujet est aussi très intéressant pour
nous parce qu'il fait qu'aux travaux de
la délégation sur la différenciation
territoriales dont on a parlé dans le
cadre de la préparation de la réforme
constitutionnelle et on voit là je crois
une application très concrète de
l'intérêt que pourrait avoir la réforme
constitutionnelle sur ce point je prends
pas position sur l'ensemble deuxième
point le désir d'alsace c'est comme ça
qu'il est défini par le préfet c'est à
dire le désir d'une entité alsacienne
regroupons nous rapprochons d'une façon
ou d'une autre les départements du
bas-rhin y aura existe deux façons
ancien parmi les populations et les élus
on peut dire moi j'ai eu quelques
échanges chez lui un certain nombre de
documents depuis que il ya un vrai
consensus par rapport par rapport à ça
il ya eu certes
un référendum en 2013 si je ne me trompe
pas ou qu'ils avaient un résultat mitigé
1 par rapport à sa quête qui prenais pas
une fusion des départements
mais incontestablement oui oui alors est
élu depuis effectivement la création des
nouvelles régions je pense que le sujet
des nouvelles régions a rendu ce désir
désir d'alsace probablement un peu plus
fort et troisième point les modalités
d'un groupement oda rapprochement des
deux départements ne se dit ne dessine
pas de façon évidente
le rapport du préfet marc décrit de
façon très précise
je vous renvoie ce document quatre
scénarios scénarii envisageables
envisageable du modèle le moins intégrés
modèle le plus intégré le premier c'est
une simple coopération
interdépartementale renforcer le second
scénario c'est la création d'un syndicat
mixte regroupant ces deux départements
le troisième c'est la fusion des deux
départements au sein des départements
unique d'alsace avec l'intégration mais
dans le temps d'un certain nombre de
compétences qui seraient pas spécifié
dans cette phase 1 mais qui suppose pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles en tous
les cas que la réforme consulaire soit
soit soit votée puis troisièmement la
création d'une collectivité à statut
particulier avec l'idée que d'entrée 7
cette collectivité à statut particulier
à intégrer un certain nombre de deux de
compétences
ce que je crois comprendre des
différents échanges que j'ai eus
là aussi je vous livre cette réflexion
la majorité des alsaciens et des élus
sont aujourd'hui pour les scénarios 3 ou
4 et très peu sont donc pour les raisons
que j'ai expliqué avant son sur les
scénarios de faible intégration puisque
j'ai parlé des compétences pour dire que
les compétences qu'ils reviennent qui
sont dans le dans le rapport
et qui sont reprises pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles par les différents
élus vous avez des sujets de
transfrontalier évidemment économique
éducation
vous avez sujet de biens wismes vous
avez des sujets d'euros dans tous les
cas d'une un certain nombre de 2 2 km de
routes et d'autoroutes et puis vous avez
des sujets de culture de sport et
d'autre à ce stade ce sera mon dernier
point avant de vous laisser la parole il
n'est pas possible au vu de ce rapport
il soit de toute façon prématurée
d'opter pour l'une ou l'autre des
options ouvertes
mais en tout état de cause la solution
retenue devra respecter deux principes
et c'est écrit là aussi dans ce rap ce
rapport un la concertation avec
l'ensemble des élus concernés devra être
permanente est mené de façon loyale et
transparente
c'est je crois ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui puisque à des discussions
importantes entre le gouvernement et les
élus
deuxièmement le souci de ne pas
déséquilibrer le territoire régional
devant prévaloir et en particulier
l'appartenance de l'alsace à la région
contestent ne saurait être mis en cause
ça a été c'est dans ce rapport et ça a
été redit clairement par la ministre
gourou récemment voilà donc j'espère
qu'à certains d'entre vous ont eu le
temps de lire ce rapport qui est
vraiment très intéressant et qui met à
jour l'intérêt de prendre en compte les
différences de nos différents
territoires je vous propose maintenant
d'ouvrir le débat
oui merci monsieur le président le
d'abord une première remarque c'est
qu'une majorité des alsaciens sont pour
la sortie du grand est c'est une réalité
qui a été démontré dans des sondages
vous avez huit alsaciens sur dix qui
souhaitent sortir d'une ronde est le
président la république a indiqué qu'il
souhaite que l'alsace reste dans grand
test on en prend acte et donc il y à ces
différentes propositions qui sont
aujourd'hui avancé nous avons reçu
jacqueline gourault il ya quinze jours
dans les deux départements
la visite s'est objectivement bien passé
je crois qu'elle a bien compris cette
envie d'alsace là par les deux
collectivités d'alsace avec deux départs
avec avec deux préfectures une en
lorraine dans le bas-rhin puisque ça t1
l'inde l'une des clefs de l'échec du
référendum de 2013 où il faut quand même
rappeler à tout le monde que plus de 54
% des alsaciens ont voté oui mais on a
fait des conditions de quantum et de
quorum dans différents départements qui
fait qu' on n'a pas atteint des
conditions exigées né dans le bas-rhin
ni dans le haut-rhin donc et puis à
l'époque évidemment ça a été rejetée
enfin rejeté pas en nombre qu'en valeur
absolue parce que personne ne parlait du
grand test et qu' ils mènent même
imaginer une idée paussifile que de
fusionner ces trois grandes régions
auraient parlé absurbe absurde à tous
les observateurs et puis on y est arrivé
bon par une chance une première erreur
politique des élus alsaciens s'étaient
d'accepter l'idée de partir avec la
lorraine et à ce moment là tout est
tombé puisque on a considéré que les
alsaciens étaient prêts à se marier avec
avec leurs voisins ce qui n'était
absolument pas le ressenti des alsaciens
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve devant une
proposition qui vise je crois que là et
bien citer synthétiser à fusionner
simplement les deux départements c'est
ce qui a été dit à la fin des débats par
tous les élus socialistes de strasbourg
tu te fusionner vos départements on va
vous calmer avec cette proposition
l'alsace n'a pas vocation à rester un
simple département on était hostile dès
le départ surtout dans le haut-rhin
j'étais président du conseil
départemental du haut rhin qui est quand
même un peu réticent à l'idée de
fusionner avec ce qu'on prend contre
partout certainement un
une peur de recentralisation vers
strasbourg une perte d'autonomie dans le
sud de la région c'est quand même une
région relevant d'un avec enfin deux
départements c'est représente plus de 2
millions d'habitants donc c'est c'est
quand même en termes démographiques
importants donc fusionner les deux
départements on était hostile dès le
départ maintenant
la ministre a parlé de collectivités
d'alsace on en est très content
simplement elle rentre à paris elle
donne des interviews dans la presse
et manifestement et dis simplement on va
fusionner les deux départements et on va
voir plus tard dans le cadre de la
réforme constitutionnelle si on ne peut
pas donner de nouvelles compétences à
ces départements et là évidemment on
peut compter dans aucun des deux
conseils départementaux on va voter la
fusion simplement sur cette promesse
tout à fait hypothétique
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est une loi
spécifique comme la constitution le
permet aujourd'hui c'est ce qui a été
fait en corse alors on veut pas
simplement suivre l'exemple juridique la
corse sans aller aussi peut-être aussi
loin dans les transferts de compétences
mais on souhaite simplement une loi
simple avec
avec des transferts claire de compétence
au titre des collectivités à statut
particulier
voilà malheureusement si on reste 1 2
dans ce schéma fusion des deux
départements
nos cours ont d'évidence à l'échec et ça
ne bougera pas et ça va être un thème
des prochaines élections en alsace et
malheureusement je crains avec beaucoup
de collègues ici que ça va attiser la
montée des extrêmes on avait plus de
partis autonomistes en alsace depuis des
années 20 ans ils sont réapparus sur la
scène politique avec des scores assez
étonnant ils ont fait 48 % dans une
élection législative c'est un score
relativement élevé et je romps toute la
représentation nationale
attentif à cette question les alsaciens
se sont sentis blessés puisqu'ils n'ont
jamais été consultés démocratiquement
sur cette évolution institutionnelle et
que ça peut se risquer de se retrouver
dans les urnes est ce qu'on a vu en
corse avec des collègues aujourd'hui
proprement autonomistes qui sont arrivés
au sein de notre assemblée
donc je j'en appelle à la conscience de
nos collègues pour et foudre et résoudre
cette difficulté alsacienne
naturellement l'alsace est dans la
république
le président de la république va venir
le 4 novembre prochains à strasbourg
pour pour commémorer le rattachement de
l'alsace à la france donc le le
centenaire de ce rattachement
le sujet n'est pas là le sujet
simplement que l'alsace c'est considéré
comme blessé
par cette réforme institutionnelle qui a
été très mal vécue qui a été très
malmené et d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans les
résultats électoraux les socialistes ont
été littéralement laminé 1
ils ont été littéralement laminés et je
pense qu ils le payeront pendant encore
très longtemps
électoralement j'étais un peu long
monsieur le président merci d'avoir
écouté je sens la passion de ces furst
et merci monsieur le président de me de
me donner la parole et je voudrais
simplement vous expliquez vous expliquer
une chose la fusion des régions a été
imposé sans discussion
l'alsace est une région j'étais dans
l'hémicycle pour l'ancien premier
ministre jugé cazeneuve est venu
s'asseoir à côté de moi pendant pendant
les débats il m'a dit mais pourquoi vous
fusionnez panneaux nouveau département
jeudi nous étions donc une région nous
serons un département
merci pour cette belle évolution je
voudrais simplement vous dire que moi je
suis en alsace y adhérer il ya des
réactions un peu différente un les
milieux urbains sont moins sensibles que
les milieux ruraux à ces questions à mes
choses sont pas totalement sont pas
totalement uniforme ça j'en suis bien
conscient
eh bien eh bien eh bien d'accord je
crois que il ya une le président de la
république a fixé un cadre qui n'est pas
le cadre que je souhaite qui n'est pas
le cadre que beaucoup de gens souhaitent
en alsace mais nous avons une tradition
de légitimité et de respect de
l'autorité
c'est un des fondements de la culture de
la culture de notre région on s'inscrit
donc dans le cadre de qu'à fixer le
président de la république rester dans
la région grand est
ça ne me fait pas frissonner de joie
c'est même très profondément contre mes
convictions les plus simples et les plus
profondes mais le cadre elle à partir de
là nous souhaitons une évolution la
fusion et le père un rat pour marx le
préfet a très intelligemment écrit ceci
si on propose aux alsaciens d'être un
département après avoir été une région
ils auront un sentiment de déclassement
c'est dans son essai le sentiment que
nous aurons pour ça que je pense qu'une
clé la création d'une collectivité de
par la loi collectivités qui aurait pour
origine les compétences départementales
plus un certain nombre de compétences
que l'on voudrait bien donner à cette
collectivité avec un fonctionnement
proche de ce que sont les départements
eh bien je pense que ce serait une
situation qui serait de nature à ce que
chaque partie et fait un pas vers
l'autre et d'aller vers un consensus à
consensus républicain
s'il n'y a pas un pas de cette
importance là où de cette dimension là
il n'y aura pas de consensus républicain
et moi je fais le pari que vous verrez
cette région administrée par le font pré
national aux prochaines régionales
merci monsieur le chien de berger
oui merci monsieur le président d'abord
j'aimerais dire que je me retrouve
complètement dans les propos de mes
collègues
ekstrom année et laurent furst
simplement corrigé la modestie d'eric
straumann qui précisait qu'en 2013 54%
des alsaciens avaient s'étaient exprimés
favorablement ces 58 % qui s'étaient
exprimés et malgré ce score sans appel à
l'échelle alsacienne les conditions
fixées par la loi qui était
particulièrement strictes n'avait pas
été n'avaient pas été remplies et le
fait que en 2013 ce projet de
collectivité qui suscite largement
l'adhésion des alsaciens et chupa
référendum et que deux ans ensuite deux
ans après même pas deux ans après leur
échec le 7 avril 2013 fin 2014
arrive le projet de fusion des régions
on n'est même pas même pas deux ans
après et là il n'y a pas de consultation
de la population
et ça c'est fondamental aussi dans
l'incompréhension de l'évolution des du
découpage régional
on a un référendum un projet qui échoue
par référendum
il faudrait en théorie relancer un sujet
de ce type là aujourd'hui
voilà le mode de procéder pour la fusion
des grandes régions à écarter
la question du référendum il faut au
moins passer par la loi par un débat qui
est politique et quotidien en alsace
nous on est régulièrement le week end en
semaine on est interpellé enfin moi on
ne parle que de ça on ne parle que de ça
alors il ya un élément qu'on entend et
auxquels je pense qu'il faut aussi
apporter une réponse c'est à dire mais
la corse les collectivités un peu
particulière on va parler à statut
particulier parce que ça risque un peu
trop de cliver sur ce sujet là vu l'état
d'avancement du dossier mais les
collectivités particulière elles
répondent à deux logiques bien précises
l'insularité d'une part on a des
collectivités d'outre-mer qui sont des
collectivités particulière la corse et
les grands ensembles urbains
il n'y a pas de raison que d'autres
territoires puissent bénéficier d'un
régime particulier
moi je pense qu'il faut à ce moment-là
répondre par des choses très concrètes
en alsace on a un territoire particulier
vous avez rappelé monsieur le président
un certain nombre de faits liés à
l'histoire il ya la culture
il ya un élément essentiel qui est lié à
la position géographique à la frontière
d'abord la première chose c'est que
malgré son intégration dans le grand est
l'alsace continue d'avoir un
fonctionnement nord sud et une ouverture
vers l'est n'inspire qu'à l'ouest de
l'alsace est un massif montagneux qui
s'appelle les vosges et qui finalement
coupe l'alsace de toute communication
vers l'ouest la seule communication vers
l'ouest c'est la lgv est
c'est l'autoroute qui passe au nord
c'est la direction paris et puis ensuite
on traverse la lorraine mais la lorraine
en fait la traversée désolé chers
collègues le pain et champardennais
il n'y a pas de liens économiques y a
pas de lien culturel il n'y a pas de
liens sociaux entre l'alsace et la
lorraine ou si ce n'est des effets de
bord ou des effets de contient les
médias les liens ils se font de l'autre
côté de la frontière ils se font vers
l'allemagne
et ça ça pose un certain nombre de
questions qui sont aujourd'hui essentiel
pour nous en alsace et qui nécessite
qu'on les traite spécifiquement la
question du bilinguisme
on avait je participe à l'assemblée
nationale au groupe d'étude sur le
bilinguisme
l'enseignement parle beaucoup du breton
parle beaucoup du corse on parle
beaucoup du basque on parle de toutes
ces langues régionales
trois quarts des enfants scolarisés en
alsace scolarisés en france dans des
cursus bilingues sont scolarisés en
alsace trois quarts on a en alsace un
maillage complet de l'école maternelle
jusqu'au bac dans des filières bilingues
en l'espace de dix ans le nombre
d'élèves scolarisés dans un cursus ont
doublé en l'espace de dix ans c'est dire
que c'est une problématique
contemporaine et pas archaïque ou
historiques c'est un élément qu'il faut
avoir à l'esprit et j'ai envie de dire
il faut réseau renverser le raisonnement
également parce que on nous a longtemps
expliqué qu'il fallait que les petits
alsaciens par l'allemand parce que c'est
comme ça qu'ils arriveront à trouver du
travail en allemagne
on a aujourd'hui l'effet inverse qui est
en train de se produire c'est qu'on a
des entreprises françaises qui cherche
des collaborateurs qui sache parler
allemand pour faire prospérer l'activité
économique des entreprises françaises
dans des marchés d'exportation vers
l'allemagne
donc ça c'est un élément essentiel on a
encore un élément je pensais qu'eric
commun en parlerait mais il l'abordé
très brièvement sur les routes
on a un axe nord-sud on a en alsace on a
dans la plaine du rhin entre la forêt
noire et les vosges la moitié l'alsace
la moitié de rang et en allemagne
on a un endroit 1 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
on doit avoir 10 voies d'autoroute
parallèle sur sur un sur un bassin qui
fait 50 km de large
dix voies d'autoroute parallèle et bien
en alsace elle est saturée pourquoi
parce qu'en allemagne il ya une taxe sur
les poids lourds en alsace il y en a pas
eh ben les camions y basculer en alsace
il traverse l'alsace il n'y a pas un
jour en alsace en qu'il ya un phénomène
grave qui se passe sur l'a35 et sans que
la moitié de l'alsace soit paralysé d'un
point de vue de ses circulation
routière et bien tout ça c'est autant de
régions de raisons qui font que l'alsace
à n'ont pas un statut insulaires mais un
caractère métropolitain du nord au sud
et qui justifie que ce caractère soient
traités de façon spécifique avec une
collectivité territoriale qui lui
correspondent
alors je reviens pas sur ce qui a été
dit on est nombreux à penser et une
majorité d'alsaciens penser que l'alsace
mérite une collectivité en dehors d'une
autre région qui s'appelle aujourd'hui
grand test grand test de quoi c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut se demander
le cadre a été posée par le président de
la république les alsaciens sont
majoritairement républicain ne se
satisferont pas de cette seule réponse
mais en tout cas on l'apprendra pour
commencer mais il faudra que la
collectivité qui naîtra de tout le
processus sérieux qui a été engagée avec
un rapport préfectoral avec une ministre
qui est chargé du dossier aujourd'hui
eh bien il faudra que tout ce processus
y conduisent un aboutissement sérieux
avec une collectivité qui sera dotée des
compétences nécessaires à gérer tous les
problèmes que je viens d'évoquer
merci merci merci beaucoup je ne suis
pas responsable de la création de la
région grand est un jeu et j'ai une
grand-mère alsacienne donc gelé il n'y
avait pas plus républicaine et plus
française qu'elle je peux je peux
témoigner là la parole est à monsieur
bruno sud r oui merci monsieur président
alors il ya un certain nombre de propos
sur lesquels je peux m'associer il y en
a d'autres que je ne partage pas sur le
traumatisme de la réforme des régions il
est indéniable vous rajoutez la fin de
l'écotaxe à ça et tous les efforts de
décentralisation en alsace en était
réduit à néant dans l'esprit des gens
c'est une catastrophe
la réforme des régions tadic a été menée
plus la fin de l'écotaxe c'est l'état
centralisateur qui décide de tout on n'a
aucune voix au chapitre et c'est ce qui
participe certainement à ce sentiment
effectivement qui s'est traduit dans les
sondages c'est le vendait sortir du
grand est qui à mon avis effectivement
est d'abord pas partagée par tout ce
territoire parce que je pense qu'il ya
une problématique urbain et rural qui a
peut-être
assez intéressante à voir et puis
effectivement en fonction de la question
qu'on pose on a aussi on a aussi un
résultat peut-être que l'on peut
souhaiter ou moins souhaité moi je tiens
ici à dire mais mes collègues ici
présents d'abord que je pense qu'on n'a
jamais autant parlé d'alsace ces
dernières années que depuis que
effectivement on le le préfet a été
missionné par par le premier ministre
que maintenant c'est de ce rapport donne
lieu à une mission menée par la ministre
gouro et donc je m'en réjouis parce que
effectivement ça plus les promesses qui
étaient contenues dans la réforme
consistait notamment ce que ça le droit
différenciation sont un véritable gage
d'optimisme en alsace il ya un certain
nombre de choses effectivement que sur
lesquels je souhaite revenir plein sur
la compétence bilingue graphiquement
monsieur chez l'énergie le bilinguisme
en alsace et efforts en termes de
quantité d'élèves qui sont touchés pour
autant ça a toujours sa touche jour que
25 % d'élèves en maternelle ça descend à
20% pour le primaire et on tombe en
dessous de 10% en collège et à 1% pour
l'abibac alors parce qu'on n'a pas de
prof et ce qui interroge d'ailleurs ce
que je travaille sur le sujet de façon
aigüe effectivement quel rôle pourrait
jouer une collectivité dans le
recrutement des enseignants et c'est
l'objet de travaux que je rendrai public
prochainement sur le bilinguisme
d'accord une particularité c'est que on
est certes on touche beaucoup d'enfants
sur une langue qui était défini comme
étant langues régionales par le recteur
guillon et le recteur de gaudemar mais
qui pour le coup la langue du voisin
c'est pas une langue régionale au sens
de le c'est pas l'alsacien qui est
enseignée à l'école dans la structure
bilingue paritaire
c'est bien le cours d'ahold c'est-à-dire
l'allemand écrit donc ça veut dire que
concrètement le rapport à la langue
régionale est pas aussi simple que ce
qu'on peut retrouver en bretagne au pays
basque ou en corse
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut les
spécificités sont à plusieurs entrées je
crois je rejoindre ceux chez les bergers
sur l'importance de la compétence sur
sur l'autoroute a35
je crois que je vais revenir là dessus
de l'écotaxe a été vécue comme un
affront
à la volonté des alsaciens effectivement
de réguler une situation que qui nous a
enrichis c'est à dire d'être sur cette
route commerciale c'est ce qui fait
l'espace rhénan mais qui aussi pénalise
la vie quotidienne des alsaciens et je
crois que en tout état de cause on
attendra demain l'entretien avec la
ministre et les propositions qui en
vient de qui viendront mais une
proposition d'une collectivité d'une
fusion de départements sans que dès le
départ il y ait des choses très clair
sur un certain nombre de compétences
comme le transport en alsace ne pourrait
pas trouvé grâce aux yeux des as est ce
parce que derrière la question de rendre
alsace une identité territoriale de
collectivités il ya cette question aussi
à quoi ça doit servir
et là ça va servir à mieux traiter les
problèmes qui se posent deux alsaciens
et c'est pour ça que bien entendu la
question la différenciation est
absolument essentielle et j'espère que
la ministre gouro pourra nous éclairer
aussi sur le calendrier parce que sans
une vision claire du calendrier on ne
peut pas y arriver et pour autant je
tiens ici à redire que je m'inscris
totalement en faux quand à des propos
qui aurait assimilé l'intégration de
l'alsace au grotesque comme un
nivellement par le bas
je crois que l'alsace est profondément
européenne il ne savons ce que ça veut
dire que la socialité la solidarité des
territoires à l'échelle européenne et
que de la même façon que la france gagne
à être intégré à l'union européenne avec
des pays qui par certains côtés
effectivement besoin d'être aidés
subventionnés etc mais qui par d'autres
profitent de la dynamique de ces autres
pays et bien l'alsace a un rôle moteur à
jouer il faut en être fier et pour
autant l'alsace aussi tirent profit du
dynamisme des régions avec lequel les
relations sont importantes on parle du
bilinguisme permettront à me dire qu'on
ne peut pas un départ les du bilinguisme
en alsace en évoquer le cas de la
moselle donc je crois que c'est gagnant
gagnant
il faut sortir de cette situation par le
haut et j'attends donc
effectivement avec mes cours mes
collègues eux
les propositions de la ministre qui
devront être à la hauteur mais en tout
cas qu'ils devront avoir des
implications concrètes parce que c'est
bien ça que les alsaciens veulent au
delà d'avoir un retour à une
collectivité territoriale
merci infiniment pour votre intervention
je pense pour terminer et respecter
notre timing monsieur feu comme ça vous
aurez entendu
oui mais alors non m absolument aucun
est absolument aucun sujet mais quand
vous viendrez en alsace qu'on fera plus
de bilinguisme envie aucun sujet là
dessus pas de jeu pas être très longue
puisque beaucoup de choses ont été dites
peut-être quelques points clés sans
faire de discours d'abord je pense bien
sûr qu'elle n'ait pas de clivage
politique et je me retrouve assez bien
dans ce cas dit notamment un toro de
d'eric straumann le deuxième remarque
c'est que effectivement il ya une
majorité d'élus qui sont plutôt pour la
sortie du grand test et notamment
laurent furst qui était très militant là
dessus et je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion très forte et il est déjà une
avancée est très forte dans le sens de
l'intérêt général pour accepter
aujourd'hui dans la discussion de rester
dans le grand est
on est à pain peut-être on verra à plus
tard et je pense qu'il faut reconnaître
cette réflexion cette avancée
intellectuelle sa juste valeur il faut
la valoriser
là c'est un point qui est important
puisqu'on est déjà dans notamment l'élu
a l'air d'avoir fait un nombre important
de concession pour arriver à trouver un
point d'équilibré un consensus commun et
si on tient pas compte
cette réflexion d'un an on pourra pas
trouver le point d'équilibré à la sortie
je pense que là ils sont ils sont enfin
on est déjà un point d'équilibré
il sera difficile de faire plus de
concessions que ce qui est déjà sur la
table
bon sur le point des compétences rac à
plat tout dans le rapport mc sont des as
les pylônes près je pense d'accord sur
les sujets c'est à dire des compétences
transférées de l'état sur le bilinguisme
sur le transfrontalier et sur les routes
en gros et puis venant de la région sur
les questions dans un cri du territoire
de tourisme est la seule question
vraiment qui fâche la question de la
compétence économique mais je pense
qu'on peut trouver les compétences
partagées pas mal de schéma qui ont été
faits à l'époque pour arriver à gérer ce
type de compétences la question
principale le blocage principal est
celui de la région elle-même du grand
est qui pour l'instant bloc et refuse de
céder une partie de ses compagnons en
tout cas de discuter de la cession de
ses compétences pour la question est les
plus liés à la relation au grand test
réel lié aux aux élus mosellans liées au
président de la région également qui est
un facteur pour l'instant de frein dans
la réflexion que l'on mène ensuite deux
petites réflexions la première
autant je pense que le haut rhin le bas
rhin sont solidaires sur l'idée de
retrouver un département commun autant
il faut revenir résultat du référendum
puisque dans le haut rhin
le résultat était négatif il ya une
crainte des gens du sud donc du haut
rhin de d'être diluée au profit donc du
nord du bas-rhin donc c'est un ses 1.709
miranda girondins d'essence gérante un
ca jacobins de province donc si on
demande si on demande d'avoir plus de
compétences localement il faut également
reconnaître dans la new dawn nouveau
département la capacité haut rhin avoir
tes propres compétences ou en tout cas
d'être reconnu dans la répartition des
des compétences et de la façon dont
l'exercice ça c'est un point qui est
sensible également l' équilibre entre le
haut et le bas
et puis un point sur la consultation des
citoyens on a fait un référendum en 2013
peut-on échapper après un référendum
négatif donc à une nouvelle consultation
d'une certaine forme a forcément
référendum mais une consultation qui
intégrait les citoyens moi je vois mal
un schéma après l'eau un autre qui soit
un schéma qui soit fait entre un
ministre trois présidents de
collectivités et quelques élus qui
imposerait ce schéma aux citoyens donc
je vois une consultation assez large au
moins sur le projet puisque l'idée ce
n'est pas de revenir on est passionnés
sont purement identitaire on est sur une
infection de dire qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire de cette région un jour juin bruno
là dessus on veut en faire une région
dans une grande dynamique
donc c'est ce projet qu'il faut définir
au moins les consulter là dessus on ne
peut pas à mon avis échapper à une
cotation citoyenne un moment ou un autre
du processus
merci beaucoup pour ce débat très
républicain je rappelle le membre de la
délégation que notre prochaine réunion a
lieu le mardi 2 octobre à 18 heures nous
recevons le ministre jacques mézard
merci beaucoup